التصريح الامني لتفتيش منزل الرئيس
الامريكي بات موجود والوثائق السريه
المكتشفه الى السيان خمس صفحات اضافيه من
المواد السريه اعلن البيت الابيض العثور
عليها في مقر اقامه هذه الصفحات تعود كذلك
الى عهد اوباما اي حين كان بيضا نائبا
للرئيس وعثر عليها او عثر عليها محامي
البيت الابيض خلال زيارته للمنزل قبل
ثلاثه ايام قبلها بيوم وجد محامو بيض
مستندا واحدا بعلامه سريه في غرفه مجاوره
لمراد السيارات لكنهم توقفوا عن التفتيش
لعدم امتلاهم تصريحا امنيا وفقا صحيفه
واشنطن بوست وتضاف هذه الوثائق الى اخرى
مماثله بسريتها عثر عليها في موقعين احد
هدينا الموقعين المنزل المذكور والاخر هو
مكتب السابق في مركز ابحاث مباشره ليرتفع
عدد المواد الحكوميه المكتشفه بعهده باي
الى 16 وثيقه حتى اللحظه واصبحت موضوع
تحقيقات بوزاره العدل وكذلك سلاحا لزعيم
كرئيس مجلس النواب الذي حظ الكونغرس على
تحقيق يعني ذلك طبعا مشاهدينا وسط استبعاد
اي تعرض جنائي للرئيس في القضيه فالمعالجه
غير الصحيحه للسجلات وتخزين هذه السجلات
كان نتيجه لخطا من قبل مساعده الذين
افرغوا مكتبه وفقاريه فيما وصف ايضا مجرى
بالحماقه من مساعده مبديا اسفه العميق
الاحتماليه التشبيه خاطئ قد يجريه
الجمهوريون بين افعال بيضا وتصرفات التراب
[موسيقى]